hi there reject nation it's Friday it's
fast and furious Friday ffff as we like
to call here that's John that's Greg
we're the real rejects click that
notification bell subscribe hit that
like button
haha bye bye yeah you influencers yeah
alright what the hell are we doing wipe
up people are like 1:30 that's it really
reaction we're gonna watch the final
trailer I thought the last trailer gave
away like 18 minutes of footage or I
have some thoughts I want to share
well of course talk about the trailer
but there's some other thoughts that I
want to share after the trailer is done
so stick around let's watch this it's
about an event that we skipped out on
yesterday that was fast and furious for
a reason and I found out beyond the
trailer was there oh snap someone took a
photo with him her that's a her it's
grace
[Music]
we're all gonna get I said
[Music]
[Music]
favorite movie - yeah that's cool whoa
[Music]
my self
a two billion dollars worth of us
together
the people will die misters there's one
of the toughest baddest
most capable women I've ever encountered
know what I got a girl I see we do we
see her of course I think you're stupid
whoa
Oh God
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you smart self money
my name is fast and furious Hobbs and
shop my name is Harvey you know I loved
about this chair I'm gonna go into what
I wanted to say oh goodness I loved is
how it really made everyone shine here
yeah before it was like the action
scenes in the chemistry between Dwayne
Johnson and Jason Statham how it's not
there all no action all toxins I think
like all that is very much present okay
but I feel like the action too is going
to be something unique David Leitch is
directing this right and with david
leitch it's like sure he has his John
wick background and then he and fuse
some new style with Deadpool - and even
though this is gonna be ridiculous
over-the-top action there seems to be
still a way he's handling the camera
here oh yeah that's gonna be something
unique for what we usually see with
giant CGI action spectacle scenes it
still feel that I'm not gonna say it
feels grounded but it's still gonna feel
like sweeping angles that are gonna be
captured in a new way like all those
bike sequences with Idris Elba on that
like I'm assuming the wheels rotate yes
yeah like responding to his instincts or
something I don't know I wouldn't have
passed him though yeah I still feel like
there's gonna be some unique action here
because it's easy to chalk up passive
Farias - yeah it's just like crazy over
the top but I feel like the action here
will probably stand out a hell of a poly
grounded you know I just said it's not
going to be and also you know like I
thought Vanessa Kirby shine the absolute
most and this sure I thought Eaters Elba
even shined more and like before it was
like - you know is badass way we've
heard him say the black super lion super
super line the black Superman before
super la get in the black super line his
action scenes here also look awesome I
mean that this is like the highlight
stuff with him more than the hand hand
stuff will actually be everything on the
motorcycle yeah well he'll is that bike
I have no idea but I mean he looks super
formidable super fun and yeah I kind of
agree with everything you just said this
trailer does a good job
chasing all of our main players as well
as all the crazy specific action I don't
know I like this trailer sort of started
out with more of a prolonged almost
scene at least where you're like in a
situation with them first I was like oh
is this gonna be one of those preview
things than it wasn't and yeah like the
last trailer was fascinating because I
believe that was actually like one of
those trailers they send to movie
theaters to be like here's why you
should play our movie so like there's a
reason that was so revealing whereas on
this hand I thought this did a really
nice job of honing in on obviously the
crazy action but also what's gonna be
special yeah not only about Hobbs and
Shawn's dynamic but about eager cell by
EM Vanessa Kirby but you know always got
that family nothing's stronger than I
love that no matter how crazy the action
gets the family element gets that much
crazier too sure cuz you're gonna have
like you know the rocks entire family
and then Jason Statham is gonna have
like 15 relatives by the end of this
we're probably gonna meet Idris Elba's
family and then the next movie he's
gonna be a good guy who you know yeah
now we're talking there you go we might
test this right we might tested this I
thank God myself what I wanted to say
was okay so a week ago we got invited to
an event that's about an hour away from
us they're doing like Hobbes and shop
promotions Universal extended an invite
something about like you're bigger they
look up GoPro you're gonna we like speed
car they're gonna let you do a trailer
reaction at like high speeds in a car
with a GoPro onion and a professional
driver yeah supposedly that was like
insane so I had a feeling a couple
people might be invited that I know my
brother javi Kawai being one of them so
he went and he called me he's like hey
were you invited to this weren't you
here see the thing was I agreed about a
month ago to do two events at screen
junkies
to do their pre-tape 4sj news and well I
didn't know was gonna be a pretty tip
that we got there this changes had to go
on their last like official like movie
fights before they switched the monthly
and I really cared about that fight and
I also always wanted to go on screen
junkies news I
agree to that a month ago and because I
have like integral morals you know like
like I think I'm like a Keanu Reeves
kind of guy I said no to this awesome
opportunity even though John begged and
begged
I know because all I've ever wanted to
do is react to trailers and high speeds
inside of a high performance vehicle and
you robbed me of that selfishly
even though we've met black nerd comedy
a couple times the CMS screenings not a
wool chat he was there Jabba coolers and
then I found out beyond the trailer was
better this was our chance or chance we
could have destroyed burned her and then
we could have uploaded our footage
before gotten all those comment it was
like we beat her to the Charlie's Angels
trait of the reaction oh she was doing
something cooler yeah that's what was
going on
don't worry Charlie's Angels will have
one of these events too but universe I'm
letting you know we are going to watch
this
opening night if you happen to have any
more events even if it's just to sit in
the passenger seat of a still car will
go even if it's just to have the rock
insult you for five minutes you know
because yeah it would be fun if I have
to give the rock a whole psychological
breakdown in my history and then he
wants to use it against me in terms of
insulting we'll do it anything you guys
want Universal we're at your disposal
we're switching from Disney shells to
Universal shows so as soon as you guys
want something from us let us know were
your guys yeah man just you know send
that paycheck send those free hookups
for events and make sure that everybody
go our engagement is so good we'll make
everyone see your moment and make sure
to go check out the movie fights that
went up yesterday there's the most one
I've ever had in movie fights you know I
won the one I was on a month ago but
yesterday I don't want to setup any
crazy expectations here but I&I elated
it Oh full auto dilation Mortal Kombat
style subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification bell I'm pretty
sure this trailer was released to tell
us to buy our tickets for Hobbes and
Shaw so go buy your tickets or Hobbes
show supporting film industry and if you
made it this far to the end you
you might like us enough to go check out
our patreon page over there we do weekly
Q&A as well as TV show reaction stream
along for many shows that includes
attack on Titan my hero academia Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood one punch
man haunting a hill house Cobra Kai
season 2 Gotham and supernatural several
of those shows have reactions highlights
included those are attack on Titan my
hero academia which we just finished
mmm-hmm going up today three
supernatural and Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood he doesn't really do a
coverage
you